each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my plane it's my pleasure to
introduce log OVR Roger now guy is a
research faculty at the University of
North Carolina Chapel Hill and his doing
the intensive research on the GPU
programming and today he's going to talk
about how to use the TP use for database
and data mining and operations including
then so assume the audience over here is
not very familiar with graphics so if I
use any graphics terms and if you are
not familiar with it then please do us
stop in between it we have enough time I
guess the play I'm going to talk about
fast database and data mining algorithms
using graphics processors now what is
the motivation for performing
information management and retrieval on
GPUs so during the past few years there
is a massive amount of information
explosion in the web and the recent
survey from Berkeley indicates a thirty
percent per year increase in the data
sizes and today terabytes of data are
quite common so this brings us to a new
set of challenges in performing
information management such as data
organization and query processing
information retrieval using data mining
algorithms and information statistics
computations using data streaming
algorithms now due to the advances in
the semiconductor technology there has
been an increase in the process of apes
however the growth in the processing
speeds does not directly relate to an
improvement in the query running time
due to three well-known reasons memory
stalls due to the presence of cache
misses branch mispredictions due to the
presence of conditionals and resource
stalls due to instruction dependencies
therefore there is a need to develop new
algorithms that best take advantage of
the architecture and reduce a query
running time
there has been considerable amount of
work in redesigning the query processing
engine to take advantage of the CPU our
texture and the main memory hierarchy
then contrast most of our work is in
utilizing the computational power of
GPUs to design these algorithms the GPUs
are mainly optimized for performing the
fix applications therefore in order to
achieve peak bandwidth on these
processors we need to treat these
algorithms as graphics applications GPUs
also have a dedicated memory interface
which is separate from the main memory
interface used by the CPU and this is
advantageous in certain multi-threaded
applications where certain threats can
be scheduled on the GPU thus reducing
the lower on the memory bus finally the
GPUs can be used for offloading the
computation from the cpu and these
useful CPU cycles can be utilized for
other operations such as I oh now this
slide shows a side-by-side comparison of
the damage of a cpu and a GPU as you
might know it is a major portion of the
CPU die is spent in the caches whereas a
major portion of the die on the GPU is
spent in the computational units the CPU
has a high amount of core clock which is
around 3.2 gigahertz whether GPU has a
very small amount very small work or
clock which is around four-thirty
megahertz therefore GPUs are more
optimal for performing memory latency
tolerant applications also CPUs have a
small amount of high-speed caches
whereas GPUs have a high amount of
onboard memory which have high bandwidth
now this stay below the peak performance
comparison between CPUs and GPUs we note
that on a GPU the graphics flops are
nearly 1.3 teraflops whereas on a cpu it
is nearly 25.6 gigaflops due to the
specialized nature of GPUs these are
processors are more are more optimized
for corruption therefore if you note the
gigaflops obtained pervert the GPU is
nearly 100 times more power efficient
Tennessee view what this means is that
if applications are designed well on the
GPU they can they tend to be more power
efficient than the CPU based algorithms
this log scale plot shows a comparison
of the new growth rate and the CPU
growth rate during the past few years
this plot indicates that the GPUs have
been progressing at a rate much more
than the Moore's law for the past few
years and this trend is expected to
continue for the next several layers
therefore algorithms that map well onto
the GPUs will progress at a rate much
more than the CPU based algorithms now
realizing these advantages a number of
algorithm designed on GPUs these include
database computations data streaming
algorithms scientific computations etc
for more information on this you can
visit this website maintained by a ex
UNC alumni now if you look closely into
a graphics processor it is divided into
several computational units each
optimized for a specific graphics
primitive for instance the vertex
processing engine operates on a series
of vertices and transforms the vertices
the polygon setup engine then performs
rasterization operation and the pixel
processing engines perform imaging
operations finally the image is goes to
a series of fixed function pipeline
units and the data is written into the
main memory
I mean the video memory now if you
abstract this into a non graphics
pipeline we can view the vertices as is
streams of data which are processed by
programmable memory engines and the
lists of polygons when a polygon is rush
flies it generates a list of fragments
now these lists of fragments are
processed by programmable simdi engines
and then a predicated write operation
can be performed before the data is
written into the video memory now in
this talk I will be talking about how we
can design relay operations in sequel
such as connected selections
aggregations join queries stream based
operations on large data streams such as
quantile and frequency estimations and
data management and data mining
algorithms such as sorting algorithms
mining techniques such as support vector
machines and singular value
decomposition etc on GPUs I will begin
with the first topic which is how to
perform relational operations in sequel
now a basic sequel query can be
represented as a selection of a set of
attributes from a table which satisfy a
boolean combination of predicates now in
the rest of the talk I will be
describing how we can perform predicate
operations boolean combinations and
aggregations efficiently in terms of
predicates we will compare an attribute
against a constant or an attribute
against another attribute the boolean
combinations are evaluated usually as a
conjunctive normal form in terms of
aggregations I will describe how we can
perform found some max median and
average computations
in terms of data representation we
represent the data as 2d images called
textures on a GPU before a query is
evaluated a fragment program is used to
copy that attributes into the depth
buffer now this craft show province of
coffee time one GPU also that the copy
time is linear to the amount of data
being copied onto the GPU also we can
observe that between envy 35 million v40
or two successive generations of
high-end GPUs from a medium we can
observe nearly a five times improvement
in the copy operation performance and
this shows the growth rate of GPUs or
the copy operation for evaluating a
predicate we compare an attribute
against a constant or an attribute
against another Const another attribute
in order to compare an attribute against
a constant we first copy the attribute
values into the doc buffer using the
copy operation and then we specify the
comparison operation using the depth
test functionality of the GPUs we then
draw a screen filling quad at depth D
and perform the depth test now that when
we draw the quad onto the screen it
generates a number of fragments and the
comparison operation is evaluated in
parallel on all of these fragments now
this table show this graph shows the
performance of relational query on to
high-end GPUs and v40 and enemy 35 and a
high CPU which is the 2.8 nigger-head
xeon processor the CPU implementation is
optimized using simdi optimizations and
we can observe that the GPU is nearly 20
times faster than a 2.8 ghz on for
performing these operations it is
important to note that we are including
the copy times while evaluating the
query
for evaluating predicates where an
attribute is compared against another
attribute inside a fragment program the
color involved in this the columns that
are involved I am assuming a vertical
table representation well and so in
evaluating the predicates where an
attribute is compared against another
attribute inside a fragment program
become we convert it into an equivalent
operation where AI minus AJ is compared
against a constant 0 and this can be
evaluated similar to a predicate which
is comparing as a constant we assume
that the boolean combination of
predicates is represented in the
conjunctive normal form now while the
predicate operations are evaluated
efficiently using the depth test
functionality the the the output of the
predicate operations can be encoded
efficiently within the stencil test
functionality the stencil test is
applied recursively and the CNF is
evaluated I will show you a simple
example of how a boolean combination of
two predicates is evaluated on the GPU
so there we have a one which is a simple
predicate and a 2 which is a disjunction
of three simple predicates so initially
we have an entire screen with valid
stencil values which is stencil value of
one then we evaluate a one using the
predicate operation and we set the value
of stencil to one in all the portions
where a1 passes in the remaining
portions distance value is set to zero
we then evaluate be 21 in the valid
stencil portions of a one and increment
the stencil wherever be 21 passes
similarly we evaluate be 22 in the valid
stencil portions and be 23 in the valid
stencil portions so at the end of this
operation inside the screen the valid
portions are having a stencil value of
two and all the remaining portions have
a stencil value of one with enter on a
draw a screen filling quad resetting the
invalid central portions 20 now this
operation can be repeated to evaluate
CNF of any length now a range query is a
special kind of a boolean combination
where an attribute is compared against
the low values and the high values and
this can be evaluated as a boolean
combination of two simple predicates
however using the Nvidia depth bounce
test functionality we can evaluate both
the conditionals in a single clock cycle
now this table shows the performance of
range query on a database with records
up to 1 million values again the CPU
implementation is optimized using the
simdi simdi functionality if we observe
that the GPU is nearly 20 times faster
than the 2.8 we go at sea on even though
we are comparing the attribute against
two values
sumption zar hear about where the data
is when you start and you fall into the
GPU but what is the funnel result that
you get out so we are assuming that the
entire database is on the video video
card right so if the video card
currently has nearly fight well
megabytes of memory so we can represent
or most of the databases we can send a
bunch of the tables directly onto the
video card at once and perform all the
operations over there so we are not
counting the data transfer time from the
from the cpu onto the GPU this is
assuming that the entire database is on
the GPU in progress in the in the system
memory inside the media memory video
memory pure operations yeah this is just
showing the potential of GPUs yeah right
I will talk about few other projects the
period where we do send a data to and
this is the data back to the CPU and
they will see like what is the effect of
data transfer time on the on your
operations right the power is that an
8-bit value it's a 24-bit value 24-bit
fixed point value you know there are any
plans in the future to extend that you
say 32-bit floating point because
without that it seems like you're
somewhat limited in what we're testing
it looks like it but I had an
implementation where you know you can
simulate floating-point comparisons by
using eight the top eight bits are the
exponent right so you could use the
Alpha you could put in the Alpha
component of a texture perform an alpha
test and then perform a depth test so
you could simulate floating-point
comparisons or even double in terms of
comparisons it's easy to simulate
floating point or double comparisons on
the GPU said I will change
shape this particular sign this would go
slightly because this is like 30 to the
in terms of copying we are just copying
32-bit values so we are representing the
data has 32-bit floating point textures
but we are not utilizing all the 32-bit
values so it will go up slightly because
we are using the alpha dash now but but
not much
in terms of aggregations we have we will
be looking at how we can implement
different set of operations like count
Kate largest number and average
competitions described now how we can
evaluate the count operation so we use
occlusion queries to get the number of
pixels that pass the predicate test now
the syntax is very simple we begin an
accretion query and we perform a
database operation using the predicate
operation of boolean combination of
predicates and then we end the equation
query we then count the number of
attributes that pass the database
operation it involves no additional
overhead all we need to do is query the
card how many values past this
particular operation it involves no
overhead at all it's very efficient for
performing selectivity computation which
can be used for query optimization now
the next portion is computing the
creation number which is a much more
difficult query than computing the count
now traditional algorithms on sleep use
required at arrangements and these
algorithms are like quick select which
required data to be modified I mean to
be rearranged now on GPUs performing did
arrangements is extremely expensive
therefore we perform these computations
without doing any data rearrangements
and without doing any frame buffer read
Beck's because frame of red bags are
also expensive now let us look at how we
can compute the catalyzation number now
given a set of set s of values that sea
of em denote the number of values which
are greater than equal to a certain
number m and v of k let it denote the
catalyzation number then we have that
the count of number of values which are
greater than equal to M be greater than
K minus 1 if M is less than equal to the
kettler ish number similarly a sea of em
will be less than equal to K minus 1 if
I'm is greater than the catalyst number
in other words if m is greater than the
case largest number the count of number
of values which are greater than M
greater than equal to M inside the frame
buffer will be less than K minus 1 it is
a very simple thing so we evaluate one
bit at a time and we will compute the
catalyzation number
let us now look at a simple example of
computing second largest number in nine
values so initially we said m to be zero
and we know that the second large number
is 10 11 so we set the M at the a bit of
one at the most significant bit and we
see how many values pass depth touched
so over here c of em is three now note
that CFM can be can be evaluated using
the count operation so this involves no
overhead at all so since c of m is equal
to three the first bit is one now next
we have said the second bit to one and
again we compute the number of values
which are greater than equal to M so
here we see that sea of em is one and
therefore this bit should be 0 then we
go to the next bit again perform the
same operation cfms three and then go to
the last pit count the number of values
and see if M is two over here and there
for the last bit is one so we know that
the without having no any knowledge of
the what the data is on the GPU we can
compute what the second largest value is
by just using count operations so the
algorithm is very simple we initialize
m20 and we'll start with the most
significant bit and scan all the bits in
the least significant bit at each bit we
put a one in the corresponding bit
position and then we compute C of em if
c of m is less than K we make that bit 0
otherwise that bit is already one and
then we proceed to the next week now
over here we show the comparison of a
median computation using the quick
select algorithm on CPUs and the Kalish
number computation on the GPUs and we
observe that the computation time on inv
40 is nearly six times faster than a 2.8
Liga HZ on also it is important to note
that the performance improvement during
6 months is nearly three times on the
GPU for this particular quit
so how did you conclude things on the
CPU using the quick select algorithm it
is a linear time algorithm we take a
value and see how many values are
greater than equal to it and if it is so
you partition into two portions and then
you recurse and so in quicksort you
records on both sides in which selleck
you recurse on only one so it becomes a
linear time algorithm and it's probably
the most efficient way of doing it so
let's for the second part of the talk
with your streaming operation any
questions so far so this was again
assuming 24-bit numbers that you're
right right 25 24 passes 24 sheer so
once you go to 32 bits you it will be
eight more passes right right because
the exponent is in a way just performing
comparison so it adds nothing so in a
way you can do double precision or even
128-bit numbers without any problem or
shrinks so the stream is usually modeled
as a continuous sequence of data values
that arrive at a port now many
real-world applications require process
data streams such as networking data
streams start marketing and financial
data streams data grated from sensors or
even from web trackers I mean these
applications we need to perform
continuous queries as opposed to a
single one time queries such as
frequency computations quantal
computations some mean variants etcetera
now these queries are very widely
studied in databases networking
community computational geometry theory
of algorithms etc in this square is we
need to process massive amounts of data
usually in real time now due to the
limitations of the main memory the of
the amount of main memory on the PCs it
is not possible to compute the exact
very on large data streams therefore we
need to estimate the query results
instead of computing the exact results
therefore we perform approximate queries
instead of exactly this approximate
queries can either be performed on an on
the entire shree mystery as shown over
here or on a sliding window which
maintains the last few values of the end
of the shrimp now epsilon approximate
queries are deterministic approximate
queries we use the following notation in
in this talk fi quantile is a quantile
with an element of rank Phi n an epsilon
approximate Phi quantile is Annie
element whose rank differs from pike one
tile by at most epsilon n the frequency
denotes the number of occurrences of an
element f in the stream and an epsilon
approximate frequency denotes any
element whose frequency is
underestimated by at most epsilon M now
epsilon approximate queries can be
computed efficiently using epsilon
approximate summary data structures and
these can be performed by bashing
solution of a subset of window ilysm at
a broad level the epsilon approximate
summary can be constructed in three
stages we first compute a window of
elements which are then which are then
used to compute a histogram by using a
sorting operation then a subset of the
histogram is then inserted into the
summary destruction we then delete
elements from the summary which do not
contribute to the final result and their
way reduce the amount of memory required
for performing the the streaming Paris
now if you look at the three stages the
history on computation stage takes
nearly seventy to ninety five percent of
the total computation time now this
chart shows a timing breakdown of the
different operations happening on a
frequency estimation query
observe that 70 / and seventy to ninety
percent you know almost ninety percent
over here is in the sorting operation
now sorting on CPUs has been very well
studied and it is quite well understood
that quicksort performs quite better now
the performance of sorting on sleep use
is mainly governed by the cache sizes
and there is a large overhead per cache
miss which is which can be as vs.
hundred clock cycles of compute time now
sorting in case a number of cache misses
due to the irregular data access
patterns as well as a small cache sizes
available on the CPUs further we may
expect additional stores due to branch
mispredictions that may happen while
performing the comparisons an
experimental study by lamarca & Lardner
indicates that the performance of
sorting is degrading with each new
generation of pentium processors now our
goal is to design an efficient sorting
algorithm using the high data
parallelism as well as the memory
bandwidth on GPUs now many sorting
algorithms on CPUs require rights to
arbitrary locations and this is
something which is not supported on the
GPUs therefore we map algorithms with
deterministic access patterns on to the
GPU we represent the data in 2d images
and we perform a multi-stage algorithm
each stage involves multiple steps and
in each step we compare one pixel
against exactly one other pixel at a
fixed distance and while comparing we
perform a conditional assignment which
is either a min operation or a max
operation at each pixel
I will show you a simple example of this
operation on 8 data values so in this
first stage step 1 we perform a
comparator operation and a comparator
network is generated the mini operation
is performed at the tail of each arrow
and a max operation is performed at the
header feature and we can decompose the
input array into two portions where the
main operations in the max operations
are performed and we can use the texture
mapping functionality to map the
appropriate comparator operations and
then we can use the blending
functionality on the GPUs to compile the
data values and store the appropriate
data values into the frame buffer now
observe that each comparison operation
is independent of the remaining
operations therefore these can be
performed very efficiently using the
vector processing functionality as well
as this cindy functionalities of the
GPUs at the end of step 1 is input to
input as a sent as an input to the stage
2 in step 2 of stage 1 over here we
compare data values at a distance of two
again we decompose the array into four
portions use the texture mapping
functionality and compute the main
operation min and Max operations in the
final step of final step of the stage 1
we compare data values at a distance of
one
and again perform the blending operation
in order to perform the overall swatting
we need to perform 3 in 2 more stages 2
more stages now this is performed
entirely on the GPU and the overall
algorithm requires log square n steps
now each step compares n data values
against each other therefore the total
number of comparisons in this algorithm
is order n log square n now in terms of
the amount of data which is sent and
read back from the GPU it is only order
n which is very low compared to the
total amount of computational complexity
of the algorithm now this chart over
here shows the amount of time spent in
performing sorting on the GPUs as well
as the data transfer observe that the
amount of data transfer time is nearly
ten percent of the total computation
time and therefore this is not a total
bottleneck a big bottleneck for
performing computation now this graph
shows a comparison of our algorithm
against optimized sorting algorithms on
CPUs the fixed soy protein on the Intel
compiler is optimized using hyper
threading as well as SSE instructions we
observe that our algorithm is nearly 2.5
to 10 times faster than quicksort on 3.4
gigahertz p for pc this algorithm
compared this chart compares our
algorithm against prior by tonic sort
algorithms implemented on GPUs and again
we observe that this algorithm is nearly
two times faster than if I algorithms
now there are several applications where
this routine is useful
sorry what does it avoids overcome
danger by the song how this is limited
to floating point values but I will talk
about funeral data values yes any of
floating point value rearranged but yes
same array but rearranged yes there are
a number of applications where this kind
of an algorithm is useful especially for
frequency estimation quantal estimation
as well as sliding windows now in the
frequency estimation as the stream comes
in we buffer a window of data values and
we perform a histogram operation using
the sorting algorithm described above
and we then perform a merge operation
into the summary data structure we then
perform a compress operation by
decreasing the frequency of elements by
one and all the elements whose frequency
is 0 we are removed from the summary
description thereby reducing the amount
of memory required
this chart shows the comparison of the
total cpu time as well as a GPU time on
performing frequency estimation on it on
a data stream with 100 million elements
observe that the GPU time is nearly two
times faster than the CPU time and these
are results which are generated six
months back so on the new GPU so you can
expect much higher performance tips of a
quantal estimation given a window of
data values we perform the sorting
operation and then we sample the window
to generate an error for the merge
operation we take two windows with
different error values and merge them
the merged window has an error of at
most maximum of epsilon 1 and epsilon in
terms of a complex operation we take the
take a summary data structure with a
certain error value and then we
regularly sample at a particular regular
intervals and this introduces an error
now for more details on this please
refer to the paper because slightly more
involved this chart shows the
performance of quantile estimation on
deep use as well as CPUs again we notice
that the total cpu time is much more
than the GPU time and it is interesting
to see that you know as the epsilon
value becomes smaller the size of the
window which is basically 1 by epsilon
becomes larger therefore we expect a
larger number of cache misses on the CPU
and therefore the CPU time kind of
increases whereas the GPU time more or
less remains the same
we have also implemented our algorithm
on sliding windows and again the GP time
is nearly half of 13 CPU time now so
there there are many advantages of using
this kind of a sorting algorithm the
sorting operation is performed as stream
operations and dally on the GPUs and it
uses a specialized functionality of
detection mapping and learning which
have high performance as mentioned
earlier like the fixed function pipeline
has nearly 1.3 teraflops of
computational power and the algorithm as
way low bandwidth requirement is less
than ten percent of the total
computation time I will talk about some
of the recent work that we have been
doing in performing data management and
data mining algorithms and then I will
take questions so in terms of data man
is that data management we have been
working on sorting large databases on
commodity pieces so we've been trying to
extend our algorithm to perform sorting
on white keys and records perform
sorting on strings instead of floating
point data values and handle database
sizes up to 100 gigabytes not things
which fit inside the video memory now
we've been working on this sort
benchmark and the sod benchmark is
highly CPU intensive for performing
internal sorting it is highly memory
intensive due to data reordering as well
as the large record sizes and it is
highly IO intensive because we need to
transfer the data from the disk onto the
main memory and from main memory on to
the GPU so we have designed a new
algorithm using a hybrid sword and GPUs
it uses efficient texture tiling for
performing comparison operations it is
three to ten times faster than prior
gpu-based algorithms and it is general
it makes no assumptions on the kind of
data types it can handle this cache
efficient it is able to achieve nearly
40 gigabytes per second performance and
it is able to handle large data sets
most of the algorithms which are
designed on GPUs are limited to
data sets which are which fit on the
video memory so this chart shows the
performance of GPU sort against a
variety of cpu-based as well as
gpu-based algorithm of the same GP sort
algorithm on different reviews you can
notice that the new algorithm is nearly
20 times faster than you know 10 15 to
20 times faster than you sort who showed
up with the more Intel compile and it's
nearly 10 times faster than sto soy
protein this chart shows the performance
improvement of GPU sort on different
reviews we have used two GPUs which is a
high-end GP during the last one year a
geforce 6800 ultra and the high-end GPU
on this year which is the geforce 7800
gtx and we have seen a 5x improvement in
the computational performance / you we
have also released a library for
performing the sorting operations on
GPUs and it is available for download at
the URL mentioned you can try it out if
you if you want to test the performance
there are several advantages of using a
GPU based sorting algorithm on large
databases the new sorting algorithm on
GPUs is mainly used for performing
internal sorting which is the main
bottom lip now after we have moved the
new sorting algorithm onto the Jeep used
for internal sorting internal sorting is
no longer the bottleneck the motto
operation which is performed on the CPUs
has become the new bottleneck and we are
looking at how we can improve the merge
operation now the GPU sort also offloads
a CPU by removing the future operation
or the sorting operation which is
performing the cpus and it is performed
in parallel to the CPU thereby improving
the performance as we have reduced the
amount of CPU burden they we are able to
achieve a much better io performance on
on the PCs and we are able to achieve
nearly 200 megabytes per second
performance on 480 disks
and since we have moved the sorting
operation on to the GPU we have also
reduced the amount of main memory
bandwidth required for other operations
and this is useful for performing key
point of generation and data reordering
go teens on the CPU so these are some
preliminary results that we have
obtained we have used the low end PC
which cost nearly two thousand dollars a
pentium 4 3 gigahertz pc with a 280
solder disks and nvidia 7800 GPU and we
have measured the performance on 53
gigabytes of data we have achieved
nearly 190 megabytes per second internal
SWAT performance and the performance is
mainly i/o limited it is not compute
limited yet so we can add more disks and
hu much higher performance now we have
also performed a CPU base routine on a
high-end PC in particular we have used
the n soort protein which is the
terabyte the terabyte sought benchmark
winner and we have measured the
performance on a dual 3.6 figurehead
Xeon processors and this is a sixth
grade order machine and we observe that
the GPU soy protein on a 2k dollar
machine is faster than I choose much
higher performance than n soort on on a
high-end PC ever and sort of already
that is a good question it's IO
performance becomes horrible on the on
the single processor machine and this is
kind of understandable because when you
are performing sorting operation you do
not have as many cycles for performing I
oh so although I Oh does not require as
much as much CPU computation but it
requires some kind of a you know the
thread requires to be scheduled so so
effectively the IO throughput came down
significantly on a single person mission
everything one windows right we have
also been looking at performing
scientific computations on GPUs we have
designed an algorithm for performing Lu
decomposition for dense linear solvers
and this can be used in performing
support vector machine computations in
data mining the other birds on Kure
decomposition we have some initial
results and QR decomposition is
fundamental for many operations such as
singular value decomposition
computations used in again used in mind
now this is a paper that we published in
supercomputing and which will be
presented tomorrow I am just going to
give some benchmarks that we have
obtained on different GPUs so we are I
am sorry so we have performed the
comparison operations on a 3.4 gigahertz
20 m for pc with hyper-threading 1 mb of
l2 cache against atlas lap back into
implementation and we have used three
different GPUs to measure the
performance on the GPUs now over here we
are showing the performance obtained
using Atlas partial pivoting we have not
seen any implementation which is faster
than the Atlas partial pivoting sleepy
implementation which has no pivoting and
which is faster than the Atlas partial
to it and here we show the performance
of 6800 GT it is comparable to that of
the Atlas implementation the 6800 ultra
is slightly faster and the 7800 is
significantly faster nearly two times
faster than the Atlas implementation of
partial pivoting in terms of partial
pivoting the 6800 GT is slightly slower
than the Lu decomposition in Atlas and
the 6800 ultra matches the performance
of partial pivoting and the 7800 again
is around 1.5 times faster than the Lu
routine we have also measured the
performance on full pivoting and this
the performance of lapack is much slower
in terms of pulpy wedding because you
need to perform a lot of comparison
operations and you need to perform a lot
of straps and the performance on a 6800
Electra in terms of will be waiting is
much faster than that of flapping
implementation the 7800 full pivoting is
comparable to that of the sounded 6800
so we are releasing a library on
performing Lu decomposition on the GPUs
again it is scheduled for release
tomorrow but I think you should be able
to download it from this website so in
conclusion I have described a set of
novel algorithms to perform database
management on gpus I have described how
can perform predicate evaluations
boolean combinations of predicates
aggregations as well as join queries
which can use a sorting algorithm data
streaming operations on sleepy on GPUs
such as quantal and frequency estimation
queries data mining applications using
the Lu decomposition pure decomposition
routines the algorithms take into
account of the the GPU limitations most
of the algorithms in wall no date
arrangements and involve no frame buffer
rate packs the preliminary comparisons
with optimized CPU implementations are
quite promising and we have shown that
the GPU as a useful coprocessor it is
not a replacement to the CPU where it is
a useful coprocessor to the CPU there
are advantages of implementing these
algorithms on GPUs since the GPUs are
progressing at the rate more than the
Moore's law these are becomes progress
it
pugh growth rate we have offloaded the
CPU work and therefore we can use the
CPU cycles for other operations such as
I oh and we have shown that this GPU is
a useful stream processor in parallel to
the CPU the algorithms are fast with the
massive amount of parallelism available
on the Jeep use and they have high
memory bandwidth finally this is all
commodity hardware it is very difficult
to buy a PC without a graphics card
although many database servers probably
do not have graphics cards but probably
Windows Vista is going to change things
hopefully in terms of the future work we
are interested in implementing a entire
GPU lapack implementation for performing
these operations we are also interested
in performing GPU clusters for the
operation such as terabytes or they are
looking at compiler optimizations for GP
GP applications mainly in terms of
performing loop tiling and loop
partitioning algorithms as well as
evaluating the cache efficiency of these
algorithms on GPUs and we are also
looking at other geometric algorithms
such as distance field computations
collision detection etc like to
acknowledge the sponsors of our research
and my collaborators the nature and Jim
Gray students as well as the other
members of UNC gamma group questions
okay it sounds like a cheap you design
question in carter where are where you
think she fusible in some sense you know
what you're saying is that did you use
our general purpose enough and powerful
enough to you know take applications
like these database applications or some
of the other situation and reframe of
using the this sort of you know single
instruction multiple operation kind of
kind of thing you know the streaming
passes processor so you know in some
sense it's almost like a coprocessor for
certain kinds of workloads do you think
I'll meet up when you were doing sort of
the mapping of these things into the GPU
did you feel like you have the
instructions you need it or do you think
that you know do you think you needed a
wider range of instructions in order to
say right yeah definitely if you want
few things which are lacking right now
are like integer arithmetic instructions
okay if you have integer arithmetic
instructions a lot of the things can be
done much more efficiently like you can
perform compression ups on the GPU you
know so a lot more things can be done by
adding these functionalities and I think
do you want to say something about that
it's
it's a few 200 operations whether you
have crossed oh no no we don't have you
now seem like that yourself there's a
few other things the main place we don't
have full travelers on tues and
synchronization but we intentionally
don't have that is if you throw it's an
alarming trend I knowledge exchange the
sort of world it really can throw a
wrench into your credible Hans so we're
looking at ways to elect more but
realistically in the short term members
in a good way but from the basics are
just whatever instruction you want
pretty much all there in da sky so you
think we're going to continue to have to
separate you know processors 14 sort of
low latency fast turnaround time
operations and what he's been highly
massively parallel google page six it's
difficult to decide at this point of
time i think we had a workshop in
Sigmund called Damon and there was an
inmate op by by the carmen from Intel
and they talked about processor
basically which is similar to the cell
where you know a GPU kind of a thing can
be supported on the CPU so ultimately
whatever we are doing you know these are
becomes will map onto those kind of
processors so in terms of research it is
interesting to see what you could do if
you have this kind of an architecture
rather than to say that this is the
architecture to perform all of these
competitions definitely there are plus
points for having these kind of
architectures like you have a dedicated
memory interface you know so it's if you
want to basically have two processes
with two different interfaces memory
interfaces it's it's difficult I mean
you need to buy two pieces essentially
with a graphics card you could put
another processor you know on the on the
same motherboard or maybe put 44
graphics cards on the same mother
so so those kind of things get more
relaxed so that's a good question what
kind of an architecture would put solve
these problems well programming these
these 30 program in the same array is
OpenGL and Microsoft latex and each of
them have their own set of
functionalities there are some places
and some minuses you know some things
are better implemented in direct take
some better in OpenGL but in most cases
you will get you know reasonably good
performance in both the api's but yeah
programming these residuals are is much
more difficult and then I mean you need
to have some kind of a graphics back
room Vegas to program these processors
which there are there are some compilers
which allow you to perform
general-purpose programming like book
GPU but they are limited in their own
their own ways you will get some kind of
a performance but i do not know if it is
good enough
so most of the number here is assumed
that player is already a GP all right so
if you are pursuing a productive
transported datacrons a severe memory of
language and to the GPU so how efficient
unit is communication country and you
think this kind of operations can be
there it's a I mean today I think the
bandwidth is nearly 1.4 gigabytes per
second right so essentially you can get
nearly 1.4 gigabytes per second data
transfer speeds onto the onto the sea
onto the video card and from the main
memory you get nearly like you know i am
the peak performance is six point four
gigabytes per second you never get the
peak performance it's like two gigabytes
per second or three gigabytes per second
it's comparable to send the data you
know in terms of the bandwidth that you
get it is comparable to that to
accessing data from the main memory
itself it's not really that big of a
problem different passes now it's a
different bus yeah isn't that it was
used for other things I mean are you
degrading the performance of some other
part of the regime by moving this data
back and forth yeah I mean boss
we are gonna consume every man with an
Arden has it from one of the other buses
that you're talking about the most part
here's a dedicated photographs right
unless you have an infinite band card or
you know some kind of a cargo yeah right
so really shouldn't have any side
effects on other behavior of the Machine
get beer one of the benefits here is
getting additional getting passively
parallel processing having accusing the
see you for something else which only
makes sense of courses great resources
needs are available right we will be
hogging all the game put my cycles right
okay a small a small bit the
transfer speeds at you of your loss of
this I think here on the transfer fees
that you're putting that what you just
said applies if your data is sitting in
so a block memory just transfer I'll
walk right great so when you transfer
the data it is transferred at the
texture which is you know an array of
data values so it is all contiguous
sleep or out which is scattered around
memory by saying its array of records
right right of course we take them out
then
copy the whole bicycle chunks copy alien
right right right yeah and that is the
same amount of work that you do even on
a cpu right your performance will be I
think your performance will get affected
drastically if you randomly access data
values so i'm not sure if Hamas gained
great great okay okay Emma if you're
talking about data sizes which are less
than one in Dean sighs maybe but if you
are accessing the main memory I am not
sure if she will get maximum performance
good enough buttons if you access random
data values obviously there's a lot that
you're holding here I think of them as
they should be just jump or you know I
you
the best that you can get an ideal
situation right quick but some other way
well you have the right pre-order Lee so
the the way to think about this is to
see the potential of this processor and
to rethink how we can design the
algorithms to better match the
capabilities of this kind of an
architecture I don't think the
traditional algorithms that we have
designed on the CPUs will map directly
onto the GPU so you need to organize the
data differentially and a lot of
research basically is going on going on
is basically how do you do this like on
the cpu quicksort may be the best way of
doing things it's quite fast put on it
on a GPU this won't map so you can use
you use the N log square n algorithm
which is still fast but you know you
can't just use a night login other with
them yes it's a single instruction
shader right on a lot of your benchmarks
you use some of the special purpose
pieces of the graphics pipeline alrighty
Jeff test and test the alpha test okay
and also I guess some kind of texture
remapping in the sort my understanding
is that things are moving more and more
towards kind of a uniform architecture
where everything is accessible from all
the different stages of the shader
pipeline do you think that going forward
in the future it'll still be important
to be using these kind of like
specialized day for the depth test what
do you think we're moving to a world
where you could get the same performance
by writing the equivalent thing it's a
pickle chips yeah you may be able to do
the same thing you know anything that we
do using texture mapping can be done
essentially by using a fragment shader
but currently you know on the current
jeep use the fixed function pipeline has
a much higher computational power than
the shader it's it's free of cost
actually and it's a separate unit
happening on a on the inside the
pipeline so things can be done in
parallel so you get much higher
performance if you can map it onto these
portions and these are fundamental
operations using games I am not sure if
if if the graphics chip companies would
stay away from from something which is
giving so much power unless you have
some way of doing it inside the sheer
due to its so which gives you the same
performance okay